le moins que l'on puisse dire c'est que
samuel etienne est un homme discret pts
en seulement cinq ans il est devenu une
figure emblématique de france
télévisions ça fait cinq ans que j'ai
l'honneur de présenter cette nouvelle
émission questions pour un champion en
2016 il remplace l'iconique julien
lepers à la présentation d'une émission
questions pour un champion
savage encore un petit peu de souffle si
certains craignaient le pire samuel
etienne a su s'imposer et s'approprier
les missions faisant oublier son
prédécesseur sans compter qu'en plus de
sa présence quotidienne sur france 3 le
journaliste est aussi présent sur la
chaine france info il y anime la
matinale troisième confinement ou pas
mais je ne sais pas une présence
quotidienne sur le groupe france
télévision qui ne semble pas lui suffire
car en plus de ses activités à la télé
samuel etienne est présent sur twitter
la plateforme de streaming vidéo en
direct sur laquelle il présente un
programme autour de l'actualité destiné
aux plus jeunes
en quelques années samuel etienne semble
être devenu presque malgré lui un visage
important du service public alors samuel
etienne le nouvel homme fort de france
télévisions voilà la question et lancer
le débat est posé
nelia est ce que vous connaissez bien la
carrière de cette spéciale était même
pas nés là mais actuellement est ce que
vous le connaissez pas du tout en étant
passionnants émission questions pour un
champion moyenne d'âge non vous ne
regardez que c'est bien sûr aussi revers
métabief trop fade mais non mais je vais
pas toujours c'est une très bonne
émission as-tu response force à tout le
monde justement et les rebonds des
images
alors la question est la suivante est
utile le nouvel homme fort de france et
les brimades crime qui a toujours une
bonne note oui il parvient toujours à
jouer sur différents tableaux auront la
même à parler hein
et il tient de main de maître la mater
l2 france info et qui d'ailleurs prouvé
son endurance 2 il a récupéré questions
pour un champion il ya cinq ans et il
fait un brin de soleil qui d'ailleurs
fait évoluer naturellement c'est réglé
les autres comment les audiences sont
très bonnes et elles sont un million
cinq près combien
donc c'est mal to travel to et enfin il
est parvenu à s'intégrer sur twitch
plateforme en direct pour ceux qui ne
seraient pas et c'est la première figure
de la télévision à réussir ce virage
éditorial
ça donnait tellement l'idée que
française ils ont maintenant fait
l'émission censure twitch et que tf1
mais également le pire est trié sur
cette nouvelle plateforme
c'est vrai blier dédiée aux games et au
départ la teseo deering le mois twitch
que dc en fait y avait des gamer qui
faisait donc c'est ultra jeunes comme
audience pour moi pour moi c'est
vraiment le plus fédérateur de la chaîne
en ce moment je les adore il ya même
jean castex qui a commencé à le suivre
cette semaine est la même des regards
amusés à vous savez les petits
anniversaire qu'on se souhaite tous les
jours avec et sans et tous les jours il
fait ça sur twitter
il a cinq mille lacs à chaque fois je
suis très fan de la libye les débats
d'accord les chances pour le coup samuel
etienne c'est vraiment un animateur que
j'aime beaucoup et effectivement quand
il a repris questions pour un champion
il s'est pris des tombereaux de merde en
disant tu vas jamais y arriver il y est
arrivé pas en confinement moi je le
regardais tous les matins justement sur
les infos je le trouvais génial le
problème c'est que la force de faire le
la matinale à faire à force de faire les
jeux et maintenant on tweet il peut
faire rien d'autre en fait tout ce qui
fait déjà programmé il n'aura pas le
temps il a une vie à côté aussi il faut
qu'ils y voilà
c'est sur ce créneau là alors c'est un
homme fort mais c'est pas celui qui va
révolutionner par exemple les prime on
l'a jamais vu en prime et les chiens qui
perd peu confiné dans vers bowman et
bien justement à la place de la
direction de france télévisions moi je
lui confierait des prime le samedi soir
je sûr qu'il est capable d'en faire et
en plus il est une bonhomie une énergie
voilà il est pétillant l'antenne donc
moi je dis oui je suis pas du tout envie
en fait c'est ça balance moi je trouve
qui excusez moi mais je le trouve qu'il
n'est pas suffisamment existants et avec
normand charisme qui pourrait être
l'homme fort de la chaîne magali pour la
cjue pour remplacer j'étais le père
camille julien lepers et pour moi ça
reste julien lepers bas comparé julien
lepers julien lepers et un charisme
c'est qu'un enfer souvient julien lepers
moi cette personne
avec tout le respect chez toi tu peux
pas comparer julien lepers et almeria
sont très bons dans son vin en exercice
ne dis pas qu'il est mauvais je te dis
que tu peux pas comparer il n'a pas le
charisme et de julien là bas moi si je
tente et julien lepers session de mars